now what we can say from here this is a
generalization of the holy stanchion I
can also have a generalization for
individual terms so underneath you if I
just want one term for example remember
I said to you ah I might be interested
in the term with the biggest coefficient
the largest number whatever that happens
to be so if I just want one of these
terms
what's the way I'm going to state it by
convention I don't really know why they
choose that about they say are like it
is a normal letter to use for which
number do you want but I've already used
n to be the row of Pascal's triangle
that I'm on so they're designate like
which which term do you want let's say
the octave ah it's just it's awkward to
say but whatever okay our is just a
number R could be 1 or 5 or 18 that
would be the first or fifth or 18th term
the odd term generally speaking is okay
let's have a look at this you're on the
n throat the Pascal's triangle you say
and see and then you say well if I with
the off term this is the zero term and
the first term in second and the end of
term so this will just be in C ah that's
it now how many aids will I have and how
many bees will I have I started off with
n of the AIDS and I just count down
every time right do you notice for
instance on this the the second term
here
Kalen 0th first second on the second
term how many days are there and there
are n minus two
well therefore the number of AIDS I'm
gonna have here is n minus aa because
that's how many times I've gone a lot it
exactly the same way that those powers
of a are descending the powers of B are
ascending so I'm gonna have exactly ours
they go now I said that we were
introduced to this so you could use your
calculator so this NCR notation that's
actually what it's called you will see
it above the division sign on your
calculator I think you're right so let's
just test this out we already know
what's are these coefficients are I want
you have a look at this one here that we
did here with the power of five okay we
can actually write each of these and if
you've got you're writing your notes
there let's do it like this
this one here okay how does it fit into
this scheme which role Packers crowd
will have my honor for this particular
example the fifth row right so this not
making it would be five see which term
is ax is the careful it's the zero
determinant it's a little bit weird but
Phi C 0 is the way would say that that
means this is 5 C 1 and 5 C 2 and so on
so for instance if you go to a
calculator and you punch it say fine you
need to press shift press the division
sign you'll see that big chunk you see
appeals and then you should say 5 CQ you
hear it equals and if a fund returns to
you the coefficient you expect which is
10 okay now this is a big tribute for
the fifth row of Pascal's triangle but
suppose you wanted to know what the
coefficients were unlike the eleventh
row okay so I would say 11 C now I
already know what 11 C 0 is whatever C 0
is going to always be 1 the 0 term is on
the edge of Pascal's triangle right I
also know what 11 C 1 is going to be
because the next term in is always the
row on the of the triangle you're on
which is 11 okay but I don't know what
the next move is I have no idea so let's
go to 11 C 2 and see what happens 55 so
I don't need the whole triangle I need
to draw the whole thing I could say well
that's the next one and then I can say
11 C 3 is 165
can someone tell me what's 11c for its
own calculator 300th day 11 c5 what 460
and I'm actually going to know I need
one more 11 CCS no I didn't okay so you
can see at this point I don't need to do
anymore do I because I'm just gonna
climb back the other side climb back
down the other side I'm just gonna go
331 65 etc okay
by the way remember yesterday I showed
you some weed like magic patents in
Pascal's triangle and I said this thing
is weird this object is weird you just
add numbers and you get these weird
shapes let me show you one more thing
humor me what's 11/1 sorry 11/11 one
what's 55 divided by eleven 165
150 plus 15 300k that's an easy one
that's ready right 462 divided by eleven
forty two point you because it's 420
disappointing now you've got Pascal's
triangle in front of you right when you
have a look at other rows of Pascal's
triangle not all of the terms are
multiples of the ruler on Lenny's some
of them what if you can work out which
ones they are